this week on brian ross investigates the
fda about to approve a covid19 vaccine
for children over the age of five but
why are so many parents saying they
don't want it for their kids
dr william shafter here with some
answers
plus the mental health crisis playing
out on american streets a woman pushed
into an oncoming subway train a child
abducted by a man with a record of
mental illness an asian american nurse
knocked down and killed in times square
in new york i think that we have a real
kind of systems failure going on has the
pendulum swung too far we have to really
think of a way to get to these people
before before these things happen and
hurt other people
plus this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
editors of media
the bite administration is subverting
democracy diluting the political power
of american citizens by importing a
brand new population that is exactly
what's happening
from the law and crime trial network
this is dragon rost investigates
and good evening and thank you for
joining us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with big news on the
cuvette 19 front something every parent
needs to pay attention to the likely
decision soon to authorize a coven 19
vaccine for children as young as 5 years
old rhonda
that's right brian the plan is for the
vaccine to be given by family doctors
and pediatricians yet recent polls show
that only about a third of parents would
quote readily make sure their children
get the vaccine
well for this we're more on this we're
joined by dr william schaffner from
vanderbilt university school of medicine
and an advisor to the cdc on the covet
19 vaccine dr schaffner as always thank
you so much for joining us
good to be with you brian and you too
rhonda are you surprised that so many
parents a third of them at least only a
third are saying they're readily willing
to get their children vaccinated many
others are still hesitant
well it's a new vaccine these are very
young children and hesitancy and a
little bit of skepticism is
understandable
we do have two americas out there
a third of these parents will grab their
children by the ear and bring them right
into the doctor they've been following
this and they want that vaccine and
others they're going to hold back a
little bit see how things go talk to
their neighbors but i hope we can bring
them all in because i hope that we can
get a recommendation to vaccinate all
children 5 to 11 years of age i think
it's important for them for their health
and
to keep them in school because there are
a lot of children who've been kept out
of school because of quarantines when uh
the virus gets into their classroom
doctor from what you've seen are there
any health concerns any serious side
effects to this vaccine for children
that age
well what's been discovered uh brian is
that
these children five to 11 will be
getting one-third the dose that their
older brothers and sisters got it works
just as well and the side effect profile
is what you would expect with a covet
vaccine there will be some sore arms and
some children will have a headache be a
little bit achy and be out of sorts for
about a day or two that will pass so i
think the side effects are quite
comparable than all of us have
experienced with covet vaccines doctor a
question for you from rhonda schwartz
rhonda
in developing this vaccine the dose and
the safety for use in children did
families actually volunteer for their
children to be vaccinated
oh rhonda did they ever in all of the
locations where these studies were being
performed the notice went out and the
next day there were parents who wanted
their children to enter into the study
and mind you they had a 50 50 chance of
either getting the vaccine or a placebo
but they wanted their children
to have that chance of being protected
just as quickly as possible so their
group of parents out there who've been
following this very carefully they're
very knowledgeable they want their kids
protected and i think we'll see that
we'll have a lot of early acceptors
parents bringing in their children when
the vaccine becomes available for them
doctor from your point of view how
important is the vaccine administered to
children in terms of the whole country
reaching a kind of herd immunity
well there are two things first of all
the vaccine obviously brian is to
protect the child now let's pause here
for a moment because everybody has heard
that children are less severely affected
than older persons by this virus that's
true
less affected doesn't mean unaffected
let's think about this these children 5
to 11 years old
over 8 000 have had to be hospitalized
half of them have had to be in intensive
care units and there are almost 100 of
chil children in this age group that
have died so we want to protect the
children now in addition
just as you suggest this will help
prevent transmission
amongst themselves and they're less
likely to bring it home
and less likely to bring it to
grandmother during thanksgiving or
christmas or hanukkah or whatever you
celebrate this time of the year
we've seen the trend lines with the
number of cases and the number of deaths
going down sharply how do you see
long-term where this country stands in
terms of covet 19 by christmas time and
by early next year
you see my fingers across
i hope this sustained reduction remains
sustained i hope we can seriously move
out of the pandemic phase into what we
call endemic in other words the virus is
not going to disappear it will smolder
along and we'll be doing whatever we can
to manage it the way we manage influenza
we'll have to watch it carefully to keep
it
down
talk about being manageable i've seen
some reports the cdc is considering
whether some americans might want to get
a fourth dose of the vaccine who are
they and why would that be the
we're
case
mostly brian about people who are immune
compromised that means their own immune
system is weakened whether by disease or
treatment with a medication so that they
cannot respond optimally to the vaccine
and so the thought is if we give them an
extra dose or even two extra doses
perhaps some of them can be brought up
to a level of protection these are
people who if they get the virus
are apt to get very severely ill so we
want to do as much as we can to protect
them
and in addition to the vaccine those
folks will have to continue to wear
masks and do the social distancing and
we want everyone around them to be
vaccinated
and finally doctor am i hearing you
correctly that we're almost at the point
we'll get past the pandemic stage
well as i said my fingers are crossed i
think that may be the case we're
diminishing in cases hospitalizations
and even deaths
around the country and if we can sustain
that by getting more and more of our
reluctant neighbors and friends
vaccinated i think we can get there and
finally get ahead of this virus and keep
it down
all
if there's no new rogue variant that
shows up we always have to have that off
on the side and watch it but we could
get there by this winter
by this winter you actually think so
that's some good news
well i hope so i'm
optimistic but cautiously so
we have to keep doing what we're doing
very thoroughly vaccine continues to be
important those boosters that we've been
talking about a lot recently but also
getting unvaccinated people on board to
accept the vaccine dr william shaffner
thank you so much once again this
evening for joining us
my pleasure
coming up next this country's mental
health crisis what's to be done about
people with mental illness putting the
lives of others at risk you're watching
brian ross investigates on the law and
crime trial network
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
we turn now to the mental health crisis
this country is suffering and really
failing to deal with highlighted by some
troubling videos that show people with a
record of mental illness who have been
arrested previously turned loose on the
streets and that acting out in some very
serious ways
on the new york city subway system a
woman with a record of mental illness
pushes a passenger into an oncoming
train she survived but was seriously
injured the attacker has now been
charged with attempted murder on the
streets of new york a man with a record
of mental illness wrapped in blankets
tries to abduct a child as the
grandmother frantically chases after him
he was stopped nearby and later arrested
and in times square in new york a man
with a record of mental illness attacks
an asian-american nurse who later died
from her traumatic brain injuries the
assailant had been repeatedly arrested
for crimes before but released on bail
he has now been charged with murder
to get a better understanding of what's
happening here and the seriousness of
the problem we're joined by professor
jennifer zadalis from the university of
florida levin school of law and alyssa
katz who's the deputy editor of the city
which covers new york city events in
depth like the newspapers once did but
no longer do
and professor cedelas when we see videos
of people who have mental issues pushing
a woman into the subway trying to abduct
a child and these are people who have
been in and out of the justice system
still around the street what's going on
here and how is that corrected because
of the nature of mental illness
there will be people who are suffering
from mental illness who will be in the
criminal justice system
they will be
they will be committing violent acts and
doing things that harm other people and
if these acts are based on their mental
illness
you know that's that's where we have to
look we have to think of ways that we
can deal with the behavior that is that
is in this special category where you
know for example you may have somebody
who's done something that's caused a lot
of harm
by virtue of a mental illness by virtue
of the fact that they either don't
understand what they're doing
or they don't understand that it's wrong
so you know i think it's always been
there and you know we have to really
think of a way to get to these people
before before these things happen it
hurt other people
the public sees this and says these
people should be locked up you know
whatever their issues are they should be
locked up and not on the street because
they cause harm and they're hard to deal
with
well you know i think that we have a
real kind of systems failure going on
which is a kind of combination of
reduced capacity in a lot of systems but
also elements of mental health response
that were a real success historically
that need to be revisited and improved
upon and by that i mean that we have uh
real you know people with mental illness
as they should have the freedom to live
as they choose they have the freedom to
not be institutionalized the freedom to
live in the community unless they are a
threat to themselves or others um and
that becomes uh you know makes it very
challenging to simply say okay well
somebody is decompensating you know
meaning not taking their medication
having a psychotic episode that first
small proportion of people right most
people are not violent but for those who
are violent that violence can end up
harming people and then
the question becomes what do you do in
those instances and generally you know
here in new york city the hospitals can
take someone in temporarily really know
for no more than three days um and
because of the lack of capacity but also
because of people's legal rights they
have to be back out on the street
and professor from your point of view we
know it's not just new york city it's
happening across the country what's at
the heart of this issue why are there
not better mental health facilities to
deal with people who have these issues
well um you know that's a very good
question
uh and you know i agree with my
colleague that you know using our you
know using florida's baker act our you
know civil commitment act as an example
brian uh you have to be an imminent
danger to yourself or others there's a
strong legal standard that applies
before a person can be taken into
custody because of mental health
problems uh so he does
the concept of personal liberty and you
know the right of people including
mentally ill people
uh you know to enjoy liberty and
freedoms is something that is definitely
an issue
the other problem is just bringing
bringing people for example like mr
holmes out in colorado like mr cruz here
in florida
bringing these people to the attention
of someone
who can can get something done for them
before they're able to
possess firearms uh at what point does
the nicholas cruz you know a very very
disturbed teenager come to the attention
of authorities
what can we do
at the moment he comes to the attention
of the authorities before something
dreadful happens um you know what could
what could we do before that happened
and what can we do to make people in the
public safe
at the same time that we're trying to do
something uh more effective for mentally
ill people
and alyssa katz says you have reported
and your reporters have indicated for
the new york city police department to
deal with these issues they're not the
perfect ones to handle such issues are
they are really trained to deal with
those who have these kinds of issues
yeah no it's a very um complex and
high-stakes issue so the nypd members
have been not all of them but most of
them have been that trained in
de-escalating conflicts although as
we've seen in videos and incidents such
as the the shooting of kowaski trawick
in his own apartment in supportive
housing in the bronx meaning a facility
where he was supposed to be receiving
services living and taken care of um
what you see is these videos showing
that police don't always de-escalate and
sometimes are in fact escalating the
situations drop the knife
put the knife down please sir
and so in response to that general
problem
the city of new york has begun to send
out some teams to 9-1-1 calls who don't
include nypd at all who include a social
worker and an emt although the emts are
not happy about this the union said that
a lot of members were just refusing to
go out because they were concerned it
would be risky to themselves and
professor let me finally let you weigh
in on that should the police be less
involved in dealing with these sorts of
issues these kinds of people who have
mental issues
when
when it is safe to do so absolutely
there there may be times when the police
do not need to be involved but a lot of
these cases are coming to the forefront
on a
i don't want to use the term routine but
they're coming to the attention of all
of us
based on a
an ordinary
request for law enforcement assistance
and so i i think that the police need to
be trained as well i think that they
need to be made aware
of
various ways that mental health
professionals have always dealt with
these people so it's a complex problem
and i don't think that we're going to
solve it by simply trying to separate
out a class of events where we can you
know
you know
go without police and then have other
events where we have to have police i
think it's more complicated than that
all right professor jennifer zadalis
from the university of florida 11 school
of law and alyssa katz the deputy editor
of the city thank you both for being
with us here tonight
thank you
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with what the editors of media have had
to say about fox news host tucker
carlson
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of media eight and we're joined
by aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire and aiden
tonight instead of a
winner you've chosen one big loser tell
us
that's right so uh tucker carlson uh has
been pushing this idea of the
replacement theory on his fox news show
for months now it's a conspiracy theory
that holds that uh democrats are
allowing unfettered illegal immigration
as an electoral strategy um he
contradicted himself on that subject
on air and uh we have the two videos now
i think which show how he's speaking out
of both sides of his mouth on this
so america will never be the same after
this and of course that's the whole
point of the exercise the bite
administration is subverting democracy
diluting the political power of american
citizens by importing a brand new
population that is exactly what's
happening there's no way
to justify this on the basis that it's
good for america it's not it's good for
the democratic
will these voters actually long term be
democratic voters will they do what
the
academic white liberals who run the
democratic party want them to do long
term and actually i think the answer is
no
but white liberals bring these people in
and imagine that they're all going to be
like oberlin graduates you know living
in brooklyn
you know and drinking artisanal coffee
actually no
not at all so i think long-term and you
see it in the voting patterns by the way
in texas a lot of self-identified
hispanics are enraged
by
biden's border policies like they're not
into this at all they're not liberal so
so why
so he doesn't really believe in
replacement theory if that second video
is accurate
that's right so you know just to
reiterate the concept of replacement
theory is that democrats are
deliberately importing undocumented
immigrants from latin america and
central america in order to have a
stronger electoral base right so the
idea is that these immigrants will vote
for democrats
now it's been called a racist conspiracy
theory because this idea that sort of
brown immigrants are replacing good
white americans has been a racist
conspiracy theory for for years um
tucker carlson embracing it uh is new
and he's actually gotten a lot of uh
criticism uh for embracing this theory
um but fundamentally
the the idea that new immigrants vote
for democrats
by default is something that analysts
have challenged for a while now and i
think was further eroded by the fact
that donald trump expanded his share of
the latino vote in 2020. now you have
tucker carlson who's been voicing this
theory on his show for months and that
little second clip that you saw was from
him talking on a podcast on the daily
caller podcast uh earlier this month uh
and he basically said that he doesn't
think that these vote these new
immigrants are necessarily liberals um
that they're actually quite conservative
um so the whole premise of his theory
that these voters are being imported to
help the democratic party falls apart um
on the basis of that idea so it was a
pretty striking contradiction and he's
yet to address it on his show uh fox
news uh declined to comment on our story
on it um we'll see if he ever does
address it uh
on his fox news show at this point he's
just ignored his own internal
contradiction
yeah i think so i mean there's no other
way to explain it he could say that uh
while it's a democratic strategy to
import these new voters it won't work
because they're so conservative but
that's not what he's saying on his show
he's saying that they are importing
these voters and that they will vote for
democrats um so any way you cut it uh
it's a glaring contradiction um and uh
you know knowing it it should inspire
him to maybe let go of the uh conspiracy
theory um i doubt he will do that
judging from his track record right the
theory is very popular with his viewers
and he likes his ratings no doubt aidan
mclaughlin editor-in-chief of mediaite
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight and thanks to all of you for
joining us tonight we'll be back again
next week and a big thanks to our staff
here at long crime for getting us on and
off the air
[Music]
you